hello everyone i'm alana and welcome to
my channel where today we are doing
another
q a uh the first one for 2021 may it
be a better year for every everyone
because it was
a whole thing this video is sponsored by
keeps which basically means
that we get a custom ad read that'll be
in the middle of the video rather than
one
chosen by youtube but for now questions
let's do it
gabby said as an inspiring journalism
what kind of advice could you give me
um she also said i'm an 18 year old
filipino hoping that someday i'll be
able to move to the u.s to work for a
gaming company
my biggest advice for aspiring
journalists is um to actually do
journalism
and i know this seems like a very
bizarre thing to say but i think it's a
very common mistake that i see make sure
you source things correctly
make sure that you go the extra way to
get information um
because and and this is not me
suggesting
you specifically would do this gabby
just something i very very very commonly
see so i feel like it's worth saying i
think a lot of people want to get into
games journalism because they want to
share their own opinions
on video games on a platform i've seen
that word for word it's just like i
think people should listen to me up and
play gibbs for other expert
but what makes you a journalist listen
to investor calls
um reach out to developers for comment
be as knowledgeable as you possibly can
rather than just
you know rewriting a press release or
sharing something that you found on
twitter it
certainly makes you more appealing to
employers
um for me personally having studied
journalism for four years
go the extra mile with everything that
you do leading up to trying to get the
job that you want because journalism is
not about just giving opinions it is
about informing people on information
they could not get otherwise
in a lot of cases or at least in my
opinion that's what i would aspire to do
so
that would be my biggest tip go hard
investigate very similar question
rabbits foot 101 said as someone who
writes and is interested in making a
career doing so what is the transition
like from writing personally to as a
profession does it take anything from
the joy of writing
um i've been a professional writer for
nine years now so i've not made that
transition
just now um i still wrote almost every
single day while working at rooster
teeth um that's the only place that i've
ever worked where it wasn't literally in
my job title i was hired as a writer at
ign not a host and i have done creative
writing all throughout my career
including at ign but i do also get the
question all the time of like
does playing video games for a job
make you like video games less and my
answer is no and the reason that i feel
those way about those two things
regardless is that writing in video
games have always been my two passions
my whole life the two things i've cared
about more than anything else
the two things i've wanted to do more
than anything else and so i think as a
result of that i was never gonna get
over it i was never gonna get bored
doing either of those things and it was
never gonna take any joy away i just
am incredibly lucky that i get to do
them all the time sahanduyusupoor said
what do you look forward to the most in
your life in 2021
i really hope i get to go home it seems
pretty likely
there is something i would spoil it
because they said i'm not allowed to yet
but there is a big family
event sort of happening in 2021 that i'm
really excited about
and i think that the person that it
pertains to is probably watching this
video so
i'm keeping you secret but i'm very
excited
yup can't wait double up said how did
this american valley girl accent come to
be
and why is it so perfect this is a
really weird one
and i like wonder how other australians
will feel about this because i don't
know
if it's consistent but i think it is
australian women will quite
often default to an american valley girl
accent as a form of humor
this is something that happened like
when i was in primary school it's like
an eight-year-old girl being like oh my
god and no way as a joke
i don't know where it comes from uh
sometimes sarcasm is said in that
valigol accent
but it kind of means that it's something
that i've been around my entire life
despite
not being to the valley until the last
like three years so
i can't tell you how it's happened it's
just a very common
australian thing for some reason james
703 said why is everyone leaving
funhouse i don't know if you saw jon
just announced
his departure as well this is a question
that you know i answered when
bruce and lawrence left and obviously i
left
um that first up john announced that he
was
sort of transitioning to just being
talent rather than producing which means
not working that full time which is
effectively what i did last year though
i was also producing
um on an hourly rate rather than as a
full-time
employee and that made very little
difference to how i showed up on camera
so it probably won't be a big deal
part one to the answer is i would way
prefer that you go to the source which
is john
who i believe streamed today and also
put up a video of his own on his channel
talking about this stuff in depth john's
super honest and open and it's super
easy to go to him
to talk about it part two it's a big
company
rooster teeth is a really big company
people have a lot of different reasons
to leave
a big company um when i worked at ign
like 30 people
left in the time that i was there but
because ign's personalities
are just not as followed as uh
people at rooster teeth nobody really
noticed the turnover rate i don't think
is that
high for the industry and the truth is
that people have different reasons for
leaving and there isn't any one reason
i left because i got a job at santa
monica studio i don't think there's
anything that funhouse could have done
or rooster teeth in general under any
circumstances that would have made me
stay we had conversations about it and
there
they addressed there being things that
they they wanted me to do
but uh for me it was just never gonna
happen john has his reasons um namely
for him he wants to live in korea
that's a pretty big deal that's very
different to me leaving and very
different to bruce and laurence leaving
and obviously very different i adam
leaving
while i do think there are
things people don't like about working
for a big
big company like rooster teeth who's now
technically owned by at
t when they weren't previously and that
change of ownership
changing uh company culture um people
who've been there for a long time could
potentially be off put by these changes
and how many changes the company has
gone through um i didn't experience any
of that but that is certainly a broad
thing that could happen that could
affect a lot of people
and i mean especially making youtube
content
uh can be really unfulfilling or at
least i found it really unfulfilling
trying to do that professionally and
working on something so short form
um on this website where you can work
really hard and make content you
absolutely love and have nobody watch it
just because that's the way the
algorithm works and that's the way
titles and headlines work so
but i think the genuine answer my
genuine answer to this question is
just that a lot of people want to do a
lot of different things and thus you
will see people leave companies and
people join companies
pretty much as it happens almost
anywhere else
it's time to hear from keeps did you
know that two out of
three guys will experience some form of
male pattern baldness by the time
they're 35 and the best way to prevent
hair loss
if that's something that you want to do
is to do something about it while you
still have hair left
you can also get treated from home which
is what um people i've spoken
to have said is their favorite thing
about keeps or at least one of them
uh you used to have to go to the
doctor's office for your hairless
prescription but now thanks to keeps you
can visit a doctor online and get hair
loss medication delivered right to your
home
they make it easy and deliver your
medication every three months so you can
say goodbye to pharmacy checkout lines
and awkward doctor visits
it kind of seems especially important
right now uh
keebs also offers generic versions of
the only two
fda approved hair loss products out
there which you know
just a little bit important and you may
have tried them before but
probably never for this price so if
you're ready to take action and prevent
hair loss
right now go to keeps.com alana pierce
or click the link in the description to
receive 50
off your first order that's k-e-e-p-s
dot com slash alana pierce people be
people
and go roman asked alana how do you stay
on a consistent workout schedule i find
that i have a period where i'm really
motivated then i stop my schedule falls
flat hope 2021 is another great year for
you
thank you um this is a really important
question because uh
the answer is i do the exact same thing
so i'm someone who if you've been
subscribed here for a while
uh health and fitness is really
important to me when i first lost weight
i lost 40 pounds and have never gained
it back
um but i still fluctuate plenty not
enough to affect my health but
i absolutely have periods where it falls
flat uh and i i don't do it and i think
the most important thing is just
starting again
and i'd be surprised if most people who
aren't professional athletes don't go
through that same thing
so all that really matters is making
sure that you actually pick it up again
that's it mr gaming said would you ever
mentor someone and help them to find
that place in the gaming industry
i currently mentor six people basically
what that means is i sit down with them
usually once a month very specifically
ask them what their goals are and then
um line them up with websites that i
think suit
their skill sets the idea is i can't
teach someone how to become a better
writer overnight i'm not a tutor
um i'm certainly down to help with
editing and i do
do that for them but it has to be
someone who comes to me already having
those skills and what i do
is figure out what their career
trajectory what they want it's almost
like my guidance counselor
figure out where they want to go and
bridge the gap to help them get there
um because i have a lot of connections
in the games industry i already do
mentor a number of people
i really like it um it's not something i
talk about a lot truthfully because i
can't take on any more
i really enjoy it it's one of the most
rewarding things that i think that i i
do on a regular basis funky bacon
salon and do you intend on making more
music sets examples being the cyberpunk
set in the 80s 90s set um i've been
asked this a lot lately so the reason
that i haven't been
uploading as much music you've probably
seen it on my soundcloud is because all
of that stuff is recorded on
actual proper hardware my streams
that are dj streams that i've done here
on youtube are all on bad hardware
that i can't even actually use properly
so i don't really like any of them
because
i cannot physically properly dj
basically those don't exist
until i get back into nightclubs which
you know probably not going to do
right now mighty speed ass where'd your
sneaker obsession come from it's a
culture i totally don't understand how
does an australian video game jono
developed such a liking for different
color sneaks happy new year
this is such a stupid question for me to
have such a specific answer to
so i have flat feet my feet are not
actually flat
basically my ankles roll inwards which
means that high-top sneakers
add extra support obviously i wear
orthotics which are inserts that i have
to put inside all of my shoes all the
time sneakers are better for that too
can't do that in a pair of vans uh
because i'll just slip up there's not
enough room
so it's ultimately for foot support
and i asked my first pair of air forces
when i was 14
i got my first pair when i was 16 and
have been wearing
different kinds of sneakers ever since i
love jordans and i love
supras as well the colors is just like
like if i'm doing this
and i'm a person who's like right now
i'm wearing all black right um
if i'm committing to wearing the comfy
shoes i'll wear them on a red carpet too
then why not make them super colorful
that's pretty much it stupid ankles is
the answer
i have a lot of questions here about my
new job none of which i am going to
answer i'm sorry everyone i have said it
before i will not be talking about it
um i would say most of them are i'm not
i can't answer any of this stuff
george rodriguez asked now that you're
working with sony santa monica studios
are you able to work on other projects i
like you did with
cd projekt red um voice acting yes i am
allowed to do pretty much anywhere
no problems where that's concerned and i
do have more stuff coming out
this year and more things lined up this
year so
yeah that's still happening also like
related to this i think there was one
question in here about it i've had
people ask if i'm still allowed to talk
about xbox on this channel
uh yeah absolutely i can still stream
xbox games i can still talk about xbox
there are no issues with any of that
kind of thing brandon martin said your
previous career
required you to keep up with new
releases but do you ever go back and
do you ever go back any older or retro
games i find myself going back to them
quite often
oh my gosh all the time um i just
finished doom 1 and started dune 2 i
just played through
a bunch of crash bandicoot i play old
games all the time and always have
um i not even necessarily retro games
just
other stuff um i'm playing dishonored 2
again right now uh on xbox
so yes there are no uh limits just
sometimes you want to play an old game
you know so you played all the game i
play fable one
tlc all the time like multiple times a
year
mitchell van and said you looked
mesmerized by the snow on christmas how
many times have you experienced snow
a lot um it snows in australia i've been
to ski field doing snowboarding
i've seen snow all around the world um
including in the us i just never had a
white christmas before
because obviously in australia christmas
is pretty different
you go to the beach and you get drunk
and you play
volleyball or you go for a swim it's a
very different thing
yeah it was really nice because so i
went to big bear for
um christmas for about six days and
ultimately was just very isolated from
any other human completely
um completely separate from the world in
a way you kind of can't get in la
because it's so damn busy a lot of
people here basically in a nice cabin in
the woods
where you could just sit outside and not
see anyone for a really long time it was
so nice i just needed to be outdoors so
bad
it was a very good call um had a great
time but yeah i've never had christmas
where it's snowed before i've had colder
christmases in san francisco and in l.a
but even those aren't pretty cold
uh so this is my first white christmas
it snowed new year's eve did not snow on
christmas day but there was still snow
on the ground and it was
it was just very cool after seeing that
in movies and on tv shows for so long
being told like that's the real
christmas and even in australia which i
still find so weird thinking about it
now
we have winter themed christmas
decorations
like at the store you can still buy
trees with snow on them
and snow globes and they sell out
despite that not at
all being what our christmas is actually
like which seems
so strange victor roman i'll have this
be the last question i think
i said what is your most anticipated
game for this year and why my most
anticipated game for 2021
right now is always subject to change is
i death loop i'm really excited about it
i absolutely love arcane
i think dishonored 2 is game of the year
every year it's such a good game
and uh i really love this style i'm
really really excited about that game
i'm also really excited about halo
infinite
um i was cool with halo from the start
i like the way it looked because it
looked like the silent cartographer to
me i did not have any beef but i guess
i've never been a person who's like
the graphics must be amazing if they are
amazing it's just a plus but
i'm trying to think of what else is even
coming out this year i guess gotta walk
that could be cool maybe
heard some studios working on that so
that could be pretty sick potentially
we'll see i guess yeah all right that's
it for me today everyone thank you to
keeps for sponsoring this video you can
find out more
in the description below there will be a
link um other than that i will see you
guys next month
not that i'm not gonna post a video for
a month just there won't be another q a
until next month
okay bye